es ist nicht nur eine blamage es ist
auch ein vertrauensverlust die korona
app der bundesregierung hat zum teil
wochenlang auf manchen geräten nicht
funktioniert wer trägt die verantwortung
und wie sollte es jetzt weitergehen zu
diesem thema zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
mal nur in höhe verliehen von der spd er
ist der vorsitzende des ausschusses
digitale agenda guten abend herr höfe
liegen ja was regt sie an dieser blamage
denn besonders auf naja ist letztlich
egal wir diskutieren ja seit tagen darum
wer welche schuld trägt für mich am
meisten auf das ja die menschen einfach
keine warnung bekommen
letztlich geht darum am anfang haben die
bewohner waren betroffen
die bundesregierung hat sich abfeiern
lassen für die beste app der welt
funktioniert hier runtergeladen wird
bunter geladen
aber es wurde nichts mehr gemacht wird
wurde offensichtlich versäumt den fehler
auf zu finden und zu beseitigen erst
seit einem tag ist jetzt auf allen
iphones auch viele neue funktionen mit
der neuen version dar
dennoch die frage wer ist denn aus ihrer
sicht jetzt schuld an dem schlamassel
die bundesregierung die sap die telekom
die smartphone-hersteller ich erwarte
einfach von der bundesregierung dass
wenn sie zwei unternehmen beauftragt
dann auch nach geht wenn fehler
auftauchen wir hören seit fünf wochen
soll der fehler da gewesen sein er war
wohl auch bekannt bei den entwicklern
wurde er debattiert also es war ja nicht
irgendwie ganz unbekannt und
offensichtlich hat die bundesregierung
vernachlässigt dem nachzugehen als zu
beseitigen wenn die es selbst nicht kann
so wie sich behauptet hat dann bei apple
und google bei den herstellern
nachzuhaken die ich wunder mich dass
gestern als noch hieß problem könne man
selbst nicht beseitigen das müssten die
hersteller beseitigen
heute eine neue version auf den markt
kam und plötzlich funktioniert wir
werden dem noch einmal nachgehen woran
genau hier viel schlimmer finde ich aber
muss ich auch ehrlich sagen dass die app
nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird sie
bleibt auch die jetzigen stand stehen
also im prinzip die am mittwoch gab es
ja eine neue version das reicht aus
ihrer sicht noch lange nicht aus wir
sehen ja wir haben im urlaub
viele reiserückkehrer wir haben ein
corona dass europa weltweit unterwegs
ist überall gibt es verschiedene apps
die nicht miteinander kommunizieren
müssen
ich fordere deshalb dringend dazu auf
dass wir jetzt eine neue version der
korona app auf den weg bringen in der
auch mit anderen apps in anderen ländern
gesprochen werden kann auch die ganzen
grenzgänger die in den nachbarländern
arbeiten und hier wohnen oder umgekehrt
sind darauf angewiesen dass die apps
miteinander kommunizieren können
vielleicht ist es auch in der zeit ich
habe den eindruck die bundesregierung
hat keinen budget und auch keinen plan
mehr das weiterzuentwickeln dass die
privaten machen zu lassen was spricht
dagegen dass eine weitere app auf den
markt kommt die sich darum kümmert als
müssen module und schnittstellen geben
dass die app miteinander reden können
und ein weiteres problem wenn jetzt die
schulzeit beginnt natürlich auch dass
viele junge menschen die app kann
verlieren können dürfen weil die es erst
am 17 freigegeben ist also eine ganze
generation von menschen die dem nächsten
der schule sind und ja ihre smartphones
dabei haben sind gar nicht in der lage
einen kubanischen deutschland benutzen
deshalb ein upgrade für eine neue
version oder auch eine weitere app ist
ja durchaus denkbar ich habe das schon
lange gesagt und mehrere app auf den
markt parallel agieren
solange die miteinander kommunizieren
berlin bei einem privaten entwickler
oder bei einem startup sind unsere daten
denn da auch sicher wer das system
dahinter hält er dasselbe
das heißt wir haben uns für dieses
dezentrale system entschieden und diese
dezentrale system der der tracing
funktion arbeitet genau du das ist ein
quelloffenes das heißt er kann weiter
benutzt werden von vielen anderen apps
ich glaube wenn man das gleiche system
mit den gleichen grundsätzen ist das
genauso sicher ob dann entwickler andere
funktionen dazu anbieten oder nicht dass
muss man offen und transparent
kommunizieren und dann hat der user die
hüterin die möglichkeit sich eine app
auszusuchen mit welchen funktionen sie
haben möchte wichtig ist dass das system
das gleiche ist mit den gleichen
voraussetzungen transparent freiwillig
aber wir müssen jetzt sozusagen ein
upgrade haben das auch international
miteinander die daten ausgetauscht
werden können er hat den fehler
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch